[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité quelques heures de
gel et c'est toute une année de travail
qui s'envole les viticulteurs cherchent
la parade pour protéger leur production
des solutions existent nous expliquera
TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest dans
un instant un an après le début de la
guerre les réfugiés Ukrainiens
poursuivent leur intégration dans la
société française rencontre dans ce
journal avec deux employés installés
près de Metz un reportage de Moselle TV
à suivre dans quelques instants et puis
à la montagne il n'y a pas que le ski ou
les sorties en raquette la preuve dans
cette édition avec l'escalade de cascade
de glace une activité impressionnante
que nous fera découvrir nos confrères de
Télé Grenoble
et on se réchauffera quelque peu en fin
de journée avec le portrait de
l'ambassadeur mondial de la bachata sont
représentants n'est pas latino-américain
mais trois liens et il se nomme Sami el
magico tout un programme
un scénario qui se répète trop souvent
des jeux les tardives et des hivers plus
doux avec un tableau cauchemar pour les
viticulteurs français en Gironde les
professionnels ont décidé de réagir et
se prépare déjà au début du printemps
une période cruciale durant laquelle ils
peuvent recourir à de nombreuses
solutions pour contrer le gel parmi
celles-ci vous allez le voir un canon
ventilateur impressionnant ce reportage
divan branchi pour TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest
son nom le RK composé de quatre
ventilateurs et d'un brûleur ce canon
aux allures de fusée intrigues il est
l'une des dernières innovations mises en
place pour lutter contre le gel on a
réussi à protéger trois hectares ce qui
était pas l'objectif qu'on souhaitait
suffisamment donc on a des améliorations
qui ont été dans une version 2 qui vont
être essayées cette année et à côté on a
des portails avec des partenaires
scientifiques comme weather-mesure qui
nous indique un peu les tendances et les
recherches scientifiques en France et en
Nouvelle-Zélande un outil à 130 000
euros qui semble séduire depuis 2017 le
secteur viticole a été frappé par le gel
à 4 reprises ayant pour conséquence une
perte de revenus et des engagements
impossibles à honorer la lutte active
est alors une priorité des composés avec
un moteur de 70 chevaux cubota et on a
une couverture selon les la topographie
et
la version de température disponible
d'environ entre 5 et 6 hectares une
machine qui est à 57000
chauffeurette tour avant ou encore
aspersion d'eau autant de matériel à
installer à l'annonce d'un gel et même
certaines pratiques peuvent être
réalisées en amont
la gestion des sols et découvertes il
doit être qui était importantes puisque
il y a un phénomène qui est quand même
très important dans le sur le sujet
c'est l'hygrométrie dans le milieu il
n'y a pas que la température il y a
aussi les gros métriques des moyens de
lutte passive et active présenter à une
centaine de viticulteurs Girondins même
si tous ne sont pas en capacité de les
appliquer donc on est parti sur les
tours antigel donc après une grosse
réflexion à savoir quelle dispositif on
avait un vignoble qui permettait qui
était d'un seul tenant qui permettait de
d'investir dans la tour antigel j'ai peu
de gros îlots les grosses éoliennes
peuvent protéger jusqu'à cinq hectares
moi j'ai pas dit l'autre 5 hectares
prochain objectif pour les fabricants
s'adapter aux besoins de tous les
viticulteurs peu importe leur parcelle
et dans un second temps répondre
davantage aux enjeux écologiques
voilà ils sont près de 110 000 à s'être
installés en France plus d'un an après
le début de l'invasion de leur pays les
réfugiés Ukrainiens tentent tant bien
que mal de se reconstruire une nouvelle
vie en France loin de leur terre natale
beaucoup mise sur le travail pour
s'intégrer la rédaction de Moselle TV a
suivi deux ukrainiennes dans leur
quotidien l'une travaille dans un salon
de coiffure et l'autre dans un
restaurant un reportage signé et ma
Facchetti regardez
il y a un nom Tatiana quitté l'Ukraine
pour travailler dans ce salon de
coiffure mes seins aujourd'hui
l'ukrainier n'a toujours un peignant
main mais son quotidien a évolué
je peux communiquer avec des Français
tous les jours j'ai appris à utiliser
des nouvelles techniques de coloration
comme des balayage californiens j'ai
aussi appris à connaître des nouvelles
marques de produits français en Ukraine
on n'a pas autant ces nouveaux pour moi
est vraiment intéressant en voyant sa
ville d'origine Mario pool réduite en
ruine la jeune femme compte pour le
moment rester en France nouveaux amis
nouvelle appartement nouveau collège
pour son fils la coiffeuse semble avoir
trouvé sa place des sia cette année n'a
pas été facile pour moi mais je suis sur
le chemin de l'intégration j'essaye de
vivre ma vie chaque jour chaque heure
profiter de la vie une phrase qui
résonne aussi dans la tête d'Olga arrivé
en Moselle en mars dernier
je ne peux pas l'expliquer car c'est un
sentiment étrange mais maintenant je
suis heureuse car j'ai un travail en
France
manageuse d'une brigade de 40 personnes
en Ukraine elle s'occupe désormais de la
mise en place et de la préparation des
boissons dans ce restaurant de
cirque-les-bains depuis septembre
dernier si ces deux femmes ont eu la
chance de trouver du travail dans leur
branche malheureusement ce n'est pas le
cas de tous les Ukrainiens réfugiés en
Moselle
voilà et partout en France la solidarité
s'inscrit dans la durée pour venir en
aide aux personnes fuyant le conflit à
Limoges vous le voyez sur ces images se
sont 400 personnes qui ont été
accueillies dans un ancien EHPAD en
l'espace d'un an une solution
d'hébergement nécessaire pour
l'insertion explication par Alain Druot
pour cet aliment sur place au fur et à
mesure de leur arrivée nous avons pu
effectivement leur proposer des emplois
leur proposer des logements sortent et
il s'intègrent effectivement dans notre
collectif et dans notre vie gens qui
sont là évidemment ils ne savent pas
s'ils vont retourner dans deux mois dans
trois mois dans quatre mois dans 5 mois
dans 6 mois mais on essaye de les amener
vers une intégration ici autonome dans
la région de la Haute-Vienne
le reste de l'actualité marquée par
l'inquiétant recrudescence de cas de
dingue en Martinique selon les autorités
sanitaires plusieurs cas ont été
identifiés ces derniers jours sur l'île
une contamination provoquée par une
piqûre de moustique et qui peut s'avérer
très dangereuse pour les personnes les
plus fragiles alors pour contrer la
maladie et recommander notamment
d'utiliser des répulsifs d'éliminer les
eaux stagnantes ou encore d'utiliser des
moustiquaires attention à vous donc si
vous habitez LILLE ou que vous y êtes de
passage pour les vacances les images que
vous voyez sont fournies par nos
partenaires sur place devient ATV
Martinique
un conducteur de bus malentendant cela
peut sembler impossible c'est pourtant
le quotidien de Romuald Poupard dans
l'agglomération de Cholet ce jeune homme
nouvelle recrue des transports publics
locaux accomplis depuis quelques
semaines sont rêves conduire un bus et
transporter des personnes malgré son
handicap une embauche symbole d'une
meilleure insertion professionnelle qui
a nécessité quelques ajustements vous
allez le voir les détails au micro de
Frédéric Lamy pour l'intelligence locale
du choleté fallait transformer tout ce
qui était auditif en d'une forme sous
une forme écrite et c'est ainsi qu'on a
pu mettre en place des outils avec des
applications grand public enfin grand
public spécifique mais qui était qui
existait et l'adaptation de nos propres
outils internes et c'est ainsi qu'on a
par exemple la radio qu’un contrôleur
qui est sur le terrain peut rentrer en
relation avec
Romuald pour pouvoir l'intégrer comme
tout conducteur sans qu'il y ait de
soucis particulier
voilà une bien belle histoire pour
romualda qui l'on souhaite une longue
carrière au volant de son bus une belle
et longue carrière encore dans ce
journal avec celle qui débute cette
fois-ci pour tech ce chiot de quelques
mois et le nouveau membre de l'unité si
nos techniques des sapeurs-pompiers du
Gard à terme cette boule d'énergie à
quatre pattes sera chargée de sauver des
vies mais pour l'heure il est encore en
formation en rencontre avec teck et son
acolyte l'adjudant Gérald Abruzzo un
sujet de Chloé bounamo pour revient
Occitanie
n'est pas un chiot comme les autres
depuis un mois il fait partie de
l'effectif de l'unité sinon technique
des sapeurs pompiers du Gard aujourd'hui
c'est son premier jour de formation
alors là le but de l'exercice c'est de
créer l'interaction entre le entre TEC
et la victime mais là on s'aperçoit que
la balle c'est pas forcément
ce qu'il préfère donc on va essayer de
trouver un autre objet
pour créer cette fameuse interaction
si nos techniciens depuis 13 ans mais ce
n'est pas seulement son compagnon au
travail ils sont aussi durs dans la vie
alors c'est vrai que c'est prenant c'est
une spécialité qui ne s'arrête jamais
c'est à dire que forcément quand nous
sommes de garde le chien est en
permanence avec nous il est présent au
rassemblement du matin du rassemblement
du soir et à la maison forcément il fait
partie du cadre familial donc les
enfants s'amusent avec dans le Gard
l'unité synotechnique dresse des chiens
depuis 30 ans pour retrouver des
victimes égarées ou en souris lors des
interventions une unité indispensable
chez les soldats du feu grâce à leurs
compétences olfactive l'emploi de d'un
chien nous permet d'être quasiment
certain de la présence ou non d'une
personne c'est-à-dire qu'on doit leur
montrer tous les vecteurs de transport
on doit leur montrer tous les scénarios
possibles alors une fois par semaine
l'unité se réunit pour former ses chiens
et aujourd'hui c'est à mon tour de jouer
au rôle de la victime avec prime une
experte
d'ici 2 ans texte sera à son tour
opérationnel pour sauver des vies en
France ils sont plus de 300 pompiers à
être spécialisés si nos techniciens dans
le Gard ils sont huit à ce jour
trouver un accord à 27 tout en
s'exprimant dans des langues différentes
vous l'aurez compris nous parlons
d'Europe à présent dans ce journal des
élèves terminales de la Loire participé
il y a quelques jours à une simulation
d'un Conseil européen la réunion des
chefs d'État et de gouvernement du Vieux
Continent l'occasion pour eux d'en
savoir un peu plus sur le fonctionnement
des institutions de l'Union européenne
et de se projeter dans leurs études
supérieures explication récoltées par
Nathan Vaché pour la rédaction de telset
écoutez l'idée c'est de faire travailler
ensemble autour d'un objet d'études
communes donc déjà européen des lycéens
qui ont de ces éléments là dans leur
programme de terminale l'idée c'est de
tisser un lien entre le la terminale et
le poste bac pour que les lycéens
découvrent aussi nos locaux découvrent
que sont les places préparatoires et
voix qu'on a des façons de travailler
qui sont aussi dynamiques
terminer les vacances d'hiver les élèves
de Corse sont parmi les derniers à
reprendre le chemin de l'école une
reprise des cours qui ne sonne pas pour
autant la fin de l'activité dans les
stations de ski les saisonniers restent
mobilisés pour répondre aux besoins des
touristes et des locaux la preuve avec
ce reportage de télépaizé qui a suivi
plusieurs pisteurs loueurs ou encore
restaurateur dans leur travail reportage
de gars étant Nobilé et de Loïc Le
Prince
le soleil vient tout juste de se lever
sur ASCO et pour les employés de la
station la journée est déjà démarré
parmi toutes les tâches du quotidien
l'installation des barrières et surtout
la vérification du bon fonctionnement de
la remontée mécanique et pour mettre en
fonctionnement le tire-fesse Jean
Raymond répond toujours présent il n'y a
pas de temps à perdre à 9h30 les
premiers skieurs arrivent pour dévaler
les pistes si l'impression elle est trop
trop basse le fil va être moins tendu
donc le filtre dérailler et si elle est
trop tendue ça va forcer sur le câble et
là haut ça peut ça bon chiffre des rayer
ce qui va être trop tendu
François-Marie et Nico l'empreinte pour
aller installer les protections sur les
pistes
celui-ci on va le mettre un peu au
milieu pour faire un petit chicane
tous les filets tous les matelas que
tout soit bien mis que il y a rien qui
soit par terre pour sécuriser la piste
c'est pas mal puis là on fait la chicane
après il est presque 9h30 et la station
va bientôt ouvrir ses portes parmi les
vacances peut ont déjà leur matériel
alors il faut passer par la case loueur
et au pied de la station Julien loup
tout le matériel essentiel à la glisse
pas le principe c'est pas que les gens
passent trop de temps à la location
c'est plus qu'ils aillent sur les pistes
s'amuser quoi donc on est un peu comme
des restaurants où on a le coup de feu
avec
les gens qui arrivent souvent un peu en
même temps mais voilà on fait notre mur
une chose est sûre si toutes ces
personnes travaillent pour que les
vacanciers puissent profiter sur les
pistes elle crée aussi et surtout une
atmosphère chaleureuse et familiale
voilà à présent des airs du 17e siècle
dans la ville du Mans la capitale
sarthoise accueillait il y a quelques
jours le tournage d'une comédie
intitulée Les Chèvres au casting
notamment Dany Boon Jérôme Commandeur
mais aussi de nombreux figurants
l'occasion pour la rédaction de LM TV
Sarthe de s'inviter dans les coulisses
du film le temps de quelques prises
reportage d'Anthony Python
la rue de la Reine Bérangère de retour
au 17e siècle le temps d'une journée
cette ruelle du Mans sert de décor au
tournage du film Les Chèvres une comédie
d'époque réalisée par Fred Cavayé avec
Dany boono casting au fil des heures
l'unique cent tournée ici et rejouer en
boucle
des personnages voilà c'est une scène de
dialogue entre deux personnages qui
marchent dans une rue et donc l'idée
c'est que en fait ces deux personnages
marchent dans les rues de Paris à
l'époque et donc il y a de l'agitation
il y a des vendeurs de peau il y a des
vendeurs de dos enfin il y a plein de
choses quoi
150 figurants ont été recrutés au Mans
pour incarner tous ces vendeurs et
rendre ainsi plus vivant ce décor de
marché de la Renaissance la plupart
d'entre eux sont arrivés aux aurores
pour les séances d'habillage je suis un
passant bourgeois et je me déplace à
côté de dans le départ ou Dany Boon
démarre quoi on verra dans le film alors
j'espère je suis là pour ça je fais ce
qu'on me demande de faire c'est à dire
je suis très sérieux je marche à la
vitesse de Monday et je ne souris pas
bêtement à n'importe qui dans la rue le
film doit sortir au cinéma en février
2024 la rue de la Reine Bérangère elle
retrouvera sa tranquillité des ce mardi
voilà l'histoire qui nous conduit
désormais en Bretagne à la découverte
des maisons à pans de bois de Rennes
emblème historique de la ville nombre de
ces façades aujourd'hui disparaissent et
sont remplacés par des enduits mais
alors pourquoi réponse avec ce reportage
sur place de TVA à Rennes
difficile d'imaginer la ville de Rennes
sont ces maisons en pan de bois la ville
en dénombre près de 370 de véritables
témoins du passé alors nous sommes ici
dans la rue Penhoet où on a ces exemples
de maisons à Pont-de-Bois qui révèlent
très très bien comment la ville s'est
construite au cours du temps on va
occuper vraiment tous les espaces
possibles et la construction à pain de
bois elle est idéale dans ce cadre-là
parce que c'est comme un jeu de mécano
en quelque sorte c'est à dire qu'on peut
vraiment s'insérer partout mais depuis
quelques années lors des rénovations une
partie est recouverte par un enduit à la
chaux
canton Foulon un immeuble en forme bois
sur lequel on est venu enduire en fait
la façade et de l'autre côté vous avez
le 13 15 rue ponton Foulon qui est un
immeuble en panne bois visible mais qui
va être réduit à l'issue de la
réhabilitation de ce bâtiment un choix
que certains habitants regrettent je
pense que je préférais les voir
continuer de les voir
pourtant la ville a fait ce choix dans
le cadre de son grand plan de sauvegarde
et il s'agit d'abord de protéger ses
façades tout en prenant en compte
l'histoire et l'architecture des
bâtiments ce qu'on constate c'est
qu'avant milieu 17e on est sur du pain
de bois apparent des pièces nobles de
boissons utilisées et après le milieu du
17e la population augmente on est obligé
de construire plus et du coup on utilise
des pièces de bois plus fragiles moins
nobles et du coup on les enduit
justement pour protéger cette structure
en pan de bois pour le moment 245
immeubles anciens ont été rénovés et la
ville de Rennes contenterait sans de
plus avant 2030
restons en Bretagne dans ce journal plus
précisément dans la petite commune de
Pont-Aven où l'on expose jusqu'au mois
de mai l'oeuvre et le travail de Willy
Ronis le photographe français mort en
2009 et met immortalisé grâce à son
objectif la vie du monde ouvrier et
s'est retrouvailles un thème forcément
d'actualité trois ans après le début de
la crise sanitaire Xavier Patrigeon pour
tbeo la chaîne de couple télégramme
photographier les gens dans leur
quotidien montrent la fête témoigner de
ce qu'il faut préserver c'est tout cela
qui définit le travail du photographe
Willy Ronis des dizaines de clichés sont
exposés à Pont-Aven autour d'une
thématique se retrouver
cette exposition il y a un ou deux ans
avec la médiathèques du patrimoine et de
la photographie on sortait d'un moment
pas très pas très amusant pour personne
d'ailleurs et encore moins pour les
musées entre fermetures et ouverture
musée non essentiels et on avait envie
de proposer à notre public quelque chose
de joyeux de simple et c'est vrai que la
thématique des retrouvailles nous
permettait de mettre en valeur cette
confraternité qui nous lie entre entre
humains cela prend tout son sens encore
plus aujourd'hui contenu de l'actualité
mondiale des photos contemporaines qui
viennent témoigner de la fête des balles
la musique n'est pas bien loin prenez
s'était un musicien frustré il aurait
aimé être fait faire une carrière dans
la musique il avait le pleurer absolu
c'était un violoniste et la photographie
la photographie et la musique sont chez
lui intimement liés le musée de
Pont-Aven poussé à explorer des pistes à
ce jour inconnu la photographie telle
que la propose Willy ronise permet
également d'ouvrir un accès plus facile
au musée comme celui de Pont-Aven tant
elles sont universelles humanistes et
profondément ancré dans nos vies l'expo
est à découvrir jusqu'au 28 mai
allez partez à la rencontre de champion
du monde pour terminer cette édition
avec tout d'abord l'étonnant parcours de
l'ambassadeur mondial de la bachata il
n'est pas dominicain mais trois liens
Sami flétriche alias Sami el magico
vient de se voir décerner ce titre par
le gouvernement de la République
Dominique s'il vous plaît une
distinction qui vient récompenser une
passion entre ce professeur de danse à
succès et le rythme volupteux de cette
danse son portrait par la rédaction de
Canal 32 regardez
[Musique]
cette heure mondiale de la bachat
a Samuel mag
ICO Puerto Plata en République
Dominicaine du coup là c'est la photo où
justement qui mortalise un petit peu on
remet le titre à Porto Plata avec le
gouverneur dominicain j'étais vraiment
content et c'était un honneur de pouvoir
avoir ce titre là son rôle promouvoir la
bachata un style de danse originaire de
République Dominicaine dans le monde
entier la République dominicaine a
différentes danses la bachata le
merengué qu'il fait partie du patrimoine
de l'Unesco et aujourd'hui ils ont
décidé de choisir des ambassadeurs qui
permettra aujourd'hui un développer la
bachata la musica danse pour tout
commence il y a une quinzaine d'années à
19 ans il part en vacances en République
Dominicaine et il découvre une nouvelle
danse et une nouvelle culture c'était
mon premier grand voyage or Europe je
suis parti en vacances pour un petit peu
connaître un nouveau pays quand je suis
arrivé directement République
Dominicaine j'ai été pris par la culture
de ce pays qui est entre la musique la
danse le partage qui est totalement
différent d'ici de l'Occident à un
moment ou l'autre vous êtes senti obligé
de danser par l'ambiance et c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé parce que moi j'étais très
timide dans cette pas du tout donc au
bout d'une semaine j'ai refusé deux
semaines mais au bout d'un moment on se
sent obligé de pouvoir danser et
partager cette musique au fil des années
ça miss se décroche en 2010 le titre de
champion du monde de bachata en
République Dominicaine suite à ça puis
quelques vidéos qui ont fait le beau sur
Internet bah j'ai pu voyager dans le
monde entier j'ai fait énormément de
pays le Troyen est aujourd'hui
professeur de bachata traditionnel
chorégraphe juge international et depuis
2019 gérant du Barrio Latino à 3 c'est
vraiment un lieu si vous voulez
retrouver un petit peu toute la culture
latine de l'Amérique latine au Caraïbes
pour moi c'est vraiment faire voyager le
temps d'un soir d'un week-end en
parallèle Sam chaque année un festival
de bachata traditionnel à 3
voilà c'est une discipline qui a manqué
de peu son entrée dans le giron
olympique l'apnée 25000 pratiquants en
France la quatrième coupe americaprenez
était organisée il y a quelques jours
dans les Vosges une compétition
régionale rehaussée par la participation
du champion du monde 2021
Eric Marchal un reportage sous l'eau
pour rejeté télévisions de Marie Daniel
rogovitz c'est d'Hélène le plat regardez
on appelle cela à faire la carpe une
technique pour emmagasiner le plus d'air
possible avant de cesser de respirer
Eric Marchal champion du monde d'apnée
statique va tenter d'approcher son
record retenez votre souffle nous le
retrouverons plus tard comme lui ils
étaient 28 compétiteurs inscrits samedi
dernier au Centre Aquanova de
Saint-Dié-des-Vosges aux épreuves
sélectives pour la Coupe de France la
benjamine a tenu 4 minutes 20 dans une
bulle de plaisir c'est comme un rêve
entre guillemets dans l'eau et ça
m'apporte je sais pas ça me met de la
tête la préparation physique et mentale
permettent un lâcher prise et en apnée
il faut aussi arriver au maximum à
développer sa capacité pulmonaire les
meilleurs peuvent ainsi stocker jusqu'à
12 litres d'air dans les poumons ces
deux fois plus que la normale quasiment
la totalité des gens peut faire
facilement deux minutes
après on commence à faire de
l'entraînement on va respirer surtout
avec le ventre c'est à dire avec le
diaphragme faire travailler les muscles
intercostaux qui sont entre les côtes et
à force ça devient des élastiques ce qui
fait qu'on peut emmagasiner de plus en
plus d'air
le rôle du coach est essentiel surtout
sur la fin l'athlète commence un peu à
être en limite d'oxygène et à un moment
on perd un peu la notion du temps en
apnée et du coup le coach il est là
parce qu'on avait vu il y a les check
sécurité tous les 15 secondes mais le
coach lui il compte en même temps à côté
10 9 8 tout ça pour que l'athlète puisse
avoir un repère temps le grand bassin
accueillait les épreuves d'apnée et
dynamiques qui demandent de gérer les
forces supplémentaires de la propulsion
le record français de la distance
parcourue et de 300 mètres et notre
champion du monde justement s'apprêter à
refaire surface nous avons du tricher un
peu car ce reportage ne dure pas aussi
longtemps que sa performance plus de 7
minutes et pourtant eric est déçu non
c'est pas une bonne apnée là ouais non
on ne peut terminer sans évoquer Jacques
Mayol dont la vie a été immortalisée
dans le film Le Grand Bleu qui aura
contribué à démocratiser l'apnée
débutant confirmé athlète de haut niveau
ils sont 25 000 pratiquants en France
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi le grand gîte et des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]